hi David gross my questions for you are
is the notion of time a necessary
component of string theory and do you
think it is even possible for the human
brain to ever really understand the
universe
hi Meredith so you asked is the notion
of time a necessary component of string
theory and the answer is so far
absolutely in fact it's a bit
frustrating that it is hard to give up
the notion of time in string theory we
have examples now which are really
intriguing in which space some
approaches to constructing solutions of
string theory give are better described
in terms of a framework in which there
are fewer or no spatial dimensions so
there's spaces and emergent property of
physics at large distances and that's a
very exciting concept that the notions
of space that space is not a fundamental
component of our description of nature
but rather an emergent concept it might
even solve certain problems that we face
but it has not been possible so far to
do that with time time is very special
very different than space physics is
about time you know in a sense physics
the job of physics is to predict the
future given the present so it would be
hard to do way without time to do away
with time and to have a description
without conventional time because we
wouldn't know what the purpose of
physics was there was no time what would
it mean to predict the future given the
present and yet I tend to suspect that
our notions of time will eventually be
modified as we learn more and more
about what string theory really is and
believe me we don't truly know yet and
but how it will I will be able to do
without over to regard time itself as an
emerging concept is beyond me at the
moment you had a second question is it
even possible for the human brain to
comprehend the universe it could be that
our brain is limited you know I have two
dogs and I've tried to teach them
quantum mechanics and they just don't
get it no matter how hard I try they're
unable to understand quantum mechanics
and so we we understand that some
species are it's beyond their capacity
to comprehend certain things that we
understand and it might be beyond our
capacity to understand the principles
that governed the universe I'm not sure
that that's the case because there are
certain tools that we possess like
language and an advanced form of
language which is mathematics that
seemed to have infinite capability they
then they might not be enough to
understand the universe but they do have
a lot perhaps infinite capability we can
you can in fact compose sentences and
utter them that have never been uttered
before so language itself already has a
kind of infinite capability and
mathematics appears to build on that so
we might be able to we don't know and
the only way we're going to find out is
to try if we sense at some point that
the questions are getting too hard for
us to answer and that people young
people entering a field are faced with
difficulties that they cannot surmount
then we might begin to wonder whether we
like dogs have a limit or capabilities
and will not be able to understand the
universe there's no evidence of that
happening yet if it does happen we
always have another out we can start
modifying ourselves and we're gonna
probably do so anyway in order to
improve our capabilities so I'm
optimistic